thank you I'm delighted to be here
this is a place I've had the privilege
of talking occasionally and and and
mostly we've had the privilege of
routing you know strongly against having
done my graduate work somewhat north and
east of here in a small town north of
oakland but were we're not really rivals
where we're trying to solve the same
problem and we don't want to update
Adobe right now as much as it sounds
like a great idea and we don't want to
update lenovo you're not getting all
these updates but I am and my best
interpretation of this is that you have
a friendly network that has suddenly
jumped brought my mac imputed 'life i
talked i titled this talk retitled it as
you saw the original title the
experimentalists manifesto because it
gives me the liberty to go out and say a
few provocative things and implore you
to do a few things and I'll sprinkle
some research and other stuff and along
the way but it's really about a
philosophy of research and a philosophy
of ways of knowing things that I hope
will will prove entertaining and also
informative the truth is that's going to
depend a lot on you I welcome your
questions your input even violent
disagreements here and there and feel
free to bring those up even along the
way this isn't I know that being
recorded we'll run into the issue i'll
repeat questions so that the person who
comes by and watches this you know in
three weeks can hear what you had to say
but don't be shy otherwise i'll just
keep talking and that doesn't make
anybody particularly happy at least of
all me so i'm going to start with a
couple of we're going to start by making
this thing come back and start with a
couple of disclaimers disclaimer number
one I like building stuff and some of
what i say is going to come from that
perspective um but i'll tell you right
up front that i'm going to make an
argument that there's a certain amount
of research that is really hard to do
well
if you'd aren't willing to build some
stuff and I'm going to bring this up
because of points that are coming up
later point number two I enjoy the
ability to inflict the things that I'm
curious about on other people or
experimenting on others I try to do so
ethically within the confines of my
human subjects review committees and all
of the applicable laws and even the non
laws I occasionally ridicule the rules
about human subjects research because as
some how many people here have submitted
something to an IRB even for just
exemption so some of you know this for
some of you who don't anytime you
conduct human subjects research at an
institution receiving federal funds of
which this is one you need to have that
work reviewed by a review board which in
our field mostly looks and says yeah
what you're doing falls under some weird
exemption because it has no harm and
it's sort of like a survey or something
if you're doing really risky stuff like
injecting people with drugs which I know
they do down the road this makes a lot
of sense but the thing that's always
struck me as strange is that the ethics
rules all go away if you don't care
about the results their definitions of
human subjects research are that you are
interacting with somebody or getting
data about somebody in order to learn
something generalizable about that
person and so my favorite example when I
talk with IRB is about where this is a
challenge is if I have a large cast iron
skillet and I hit somebody over the head
with it and observe the pain that that
is occurred I need to get IRB approval
if I'm going to try to publish about
that strangely enough if what I do is
hand all of you a survey or better yet I
just watch you to see if you laugh and I
hit him over the head but I don't watch
him
it's exempt because what I'm giving you
as a survey and I'm not studying him and
better yet if I just think it's fun to
hit people over the head I don't need
approval at all I'm not suggesting we do
this but I am suggesting that we this is
a time that these rules are actually
currently under revision and there is
talk about taking a lot of the work that
we do that is exempt out of the
jurisdiction of normal research review
and this might be a time to watch that
if you're somebody who cares about this
in the field but the third disclaimer is
probably the most important one I've
probably read too many research papers
in the course of a career you hit this
point eventually and it gets worse when
you are willing to review the papers
along the way and I've gotten grumpy
about the fact that I see a lot of
research that after I look at it I
realize it was flawlessly executed and
has no practical significance whatsoever
and in many cases it was flawlessly
executed and has no practical
significance in a way that makes it look
as though somebody had the mission of
saying what's the least amount of work i
can do to get this work out there and
into the field rather than saying what's
the question i really want to know the
answer to and this is this talk really
goes in that direction of saying how do
we shift away from that there we go so
you're going to see three things here
you're going to see an introduction I
stole this organization there's a lot of
people who put this up if this is what
your talk is supposed to be that's
followed by three substantive sections
where we talk about deep things like the
purpose of research and observation
analysis and experimentation and what I
think maybe the area where we have the
most to contribute from our labs
experience about you know when do you
want to own your own infrastructure
versus and habit other people's
infrastructure when when of the
experiments you're going to carry out
more effective in the lab versus in the
field
and then I've been promised that that I
will be inspired to come up with a witty
and insightful conclusion and I hope
that shows up by the time we get to the
end so this introduction that I talked
about started with the fact that I'm
sort of getting bored you can find a
tweet that suggests that seventy two
percent of tweets contained up made up
facts like this one that's not all that
interesting but you could probably find
it on Wikipedia if you'd give me a
minute I've seen too many papers and I
will be honest I've seen these papers
not just from people who would say they
don't know any better I see these papers
from my own students at times I've seen
these papers from colleagues I know due
for some fantastic work that are not
exactly but are not very much different
from saying well a hundred percent of
users using our new whiz-bang desktop
desktop video conferencing system used
the space bar you see these papers with
charts of which command did each person
use and which modality thanks why why
did they use the spacebar is it possible
that a hundred percent of your users
have thumbs we don't know we distributed
the software over the internet we didn't
take pictures and of course there is
theoretical work that's going on but I
don't always find that theory stuff that
I am able to apply I refer to this as
the the meat slicer theory of
collaborative systems right that users
hang together until they're sliced apart
and then their inner strength determines
if they stay all or shred you've
probably never heard of this because I
made that one up but that's a theory you
could use it to guide things it's
completely true with the meat on a meat
slicer right that you slice the turkey
and it falls apart if it's not strong
enough it doesn't mean anything though
there's no data behind it there's no
depth behind it there's actually nothing
behind it at all and of course this is
the grumpy old guy part it it might not
have in this way in the past it felt to
me like a
I was writing this talk the first time I
started thinking about these issues that
part of what's happening to our field is
that there's more data than there ever
used to be and because there's more data
there's this immense temptation to
analyze it when some of us were in the
field that they at the somewhat earlier
stages I won't claim to have been there
at the beginning but there was a stage
where nothing was there so you had to
build everything from scratch and I
don't think we should go back to that
those were horrible days but they did
lead to a lot of experimentation so what
are we going to talk about here I'm
going to start with message number 12
quiz we're going to do this incremental
e we'll see if we all get the answers
together you know why do research how
many people think we do research because
it pays so much better than feels like
law business medicine and sports for
those watching on TV no hands went up
because it helps attract women men or
whoever it is that you're looking for
for those of you on TV one hand went
halfway up and will be left there for
the rest of the talk and if you want to
meet that hand after evermind number
three to contribute to knowledge ooh lot
of hands and because there are
opportunities we cannot yet sees and
challenges we cannot yet surmount I
don't know what that means but it really
sounds good I thought that was why we
climb mountains that have never been
climbed but yeah we we do this because
we want to do something new and we want
to learn something from it we all get
that so let's get a little narrower I
care about something very specific I
care about social and collaborative
systems and we know there are certain
failings in these systems today many of
them fail right out of the box if you
talk to somebody who builds social and
collaborative systems as a researcher
and frankly I think this is true if you
talk to people
who build them as entrepreneurs as well
what you find out is that many of them
don't work they don't work not because
they crash some of them crash too they
don't work because there was something
in the social design that failed i will
give you one of my own painful examples
we spent a bunch of time building a
community question-answering site I
think I now mostly know why it failed
but it is still the case that
three-quarters of the questions and
answers in the site were posted by
people that I either employed or paid in
the course of experiments to post
content it was a great site except for
one critical thing which is that the
social environment it was designed for
by the time it was delivered the social
environment had changed and it was
delivered to match an environment that
wasn't there anymore and so people
didn't use it you could talk about
social software engineering problems
that was certainly part of the problem
but it was also a matter of we weren't
fast enough to react and when we realize
things were changing we were too slow to
change with them it's not just my site
if you go to the wiki world and you go
beyond Wikipedia to all of the you know
wikia projects and sites that are out
there most of them lack activity this
isn't new you can go back to results
from 15 years ago that said most
discussion groups have no activity and
even those who have activity don't
always have productive activity social
systems filled with the same template
that was abused for the last one that
was good often failed because we don't
know how to adapt them to the
circumstances that are involved and
perhaps most important we often don't
know how to get them going
many of these systems would succeed if
only they were successful already and
that's not a very good recipe
unfortunately if you were to put this as
sort of a mission statement you know
part of what I want to do in life is
make these systems easier to build well
and that means moving along a path that
at one end is gambling gambling is why
don't you give us $250,000 and we'll get
a system up and running and if it works
we'll get rich and we'd like to move
from gambling to art which is where some
of this is now to design all the way out
to engineering where I'm defining
engineering just so that we have a
definition that works for this as a
well-understood set of principles and
processes and procedures that result in
a predictably performing product as a
result of the underlying science you
know the beautiful thing about
engineering in the rest of the world is
when somebody goes there and puts
together a bridge mostly unless they're
designing a bridge in circumstances that
are outside the realm of what we've ever
seen the bridge just works this is true
whether it's a bridge or whether it's a
support beam in your house or whether
it's a chip or other things they just
work yeah so you a second ago yours
without working in terms of working
socially and I'm just really concerned
whether you mean people use it that
working socially means this evidence of
use because you can have a very
functioning bridge that's built in the
middle of nowhere the choices and we
have a issue with saying that big
doesn't work agreed so let me take what
you said in two pieces of this there's
also work in traffic engineering that
can give you much more predictable
results as to whether people will use it
more predictable than we have in social
computing today I don't want to limit
the definition of working two people
will use it but I want that to be a
minimum and I think it's that people
will use it and it achieves its purpose
and you know Wikipedia would not be a
success if it had you know ten billion
views a day and half a billion edits a
day and everything in it were wrong
propaganda media might be a success
under that goal but none of us are
really worried about that so there's
some there's going to be some criteria
for this to talk about success and the
key to this is some notion of
engineering and I'll just give you an
example of the the early work we we
started doing in this area this is
something we've been working on for a
long time this is a book some of you may
have seen it edited by Bob crowd and
Paul Resnick called building successful
online communities evidence based social
design it probably should have said one
at the end because it's not complete but
it collected together a set of work done
over mostly a span of about seven years
and the predecessor work that had not
been aggregated with it to say there are
certain things we know about how people
respond to incentives how people respond
to certain kinds of social cues social
pressures there are unfortunately this
book is still mostly closer to design
than engineering because in a lot of
these it comes back and it says you know
we know this we know this we don't yet
know how they interact and how they
interact can be very important yeah by
reading on this book in the broader
literature though it like is it's not
necessarily about people will use this
because it is sort of assumes and much
of this literature that people
already there there haven't need this
community of solving but I feel like
what you're getting at is something may
be different which is that would they
come at all is there some need that's
being filled and I wonder if these
should be separated or not so there's
actually there's a chapter in here
specifically about the startup of new
communities and is there a need and
what's the niche and all of that stuff a
lot of this is how to manage an ongoing
community to it's much easier to do
research on ongoing communities in some
ways but i think that from the
perspective of who's doing the research
often it is separate the weather there's
a need to kind of thing often it's not
us this is the business schools that are
that are addressing some of these issues
other people are what the techniques are
I think is what we in the social
computing field mostly work on but they
have to work together and why do they
have to work together nothing we
shouldn't understand it I'm saying we
shouldn't claim that we're going to be
the only ones i think we have to work
with the people no now we have to do
it's often a case where we don't have
the information to take the lead but
when we do we should in many cases
they've been people working on specific
areas of market need other things for
long periods of time let's partner with
those people and get the advantage of
what they started with when we're going
forward something that is easier for me
to grasp a little bit yeah let's take
like psychopath is an example yeah came
out of their group I feel like a major
contribution that reed made there was
the notion that if this online community
could come together around a sort of
different type of activity they might
have done previously and I feel like
that is in some sense of design and
engineering contribution that but it
sounds to me the way of describing it
that would come out of a marketing
program not out of read or us yes
research agenda well I think if you
actually look at where it came out it
came out of a combination of reads CS
research jasmine people not familiar
psychopath is a the term that's been
coined for it a computational geo wiki
read pradoor ski PhD graduate our
program
intervene designed and developed the
system where you have a large map of an
area designed to be edited into bike
maps that are computationally usable to
create routes that's the fundamentals of
cyclope that you go to cyclic path org
you can see the map and when you see the
map what you'll see is any person
looking at the map like a wiki can edit
it if they find out there's something
missing or wrong in the map so they can
edit it directly and say wait a minute
these two streets they connect and on
the map they're not shown as connecting
I'll make the connection they can edit
it by annotation and say you know this
street is closed for construction
through the end of of March or they can
edit it by annotating it in a
computationally useful way that is
subjective like saying this street is is
a pretty street to bike on that people
can query around they can talk about
things like it's bumpy it's high traffic
and then somebody else can come in and
say I'd like a route from here to here
and specify preferences over the user
attributes that are there and get routes
and choices of routes and provide
feedback it's a very interesting system
and one of the great accomplishments of
that system was the ability to get a
bunch of people going and using it the
reason Reed was able to do that was that
he was embedded within the twin cities
active biking community and in cases
where you've got somebody embedded in a
community now this was not a case where
the community came to him and said
here's what we need he had an idea but
he iterated that idea through
discussions with people in the community
and he put a lot of effort into getting
some key people in that community to buy
into this idea so that it could get up
to the point where it had some level of
critical mass was there anything wrong
with him doing that of course not it was
a wonder
success not every person doing research
in social computing will necessarily
have had the length of investment into a
community that they're going to be able
to do that but when you're capable of
that when you can embed yourself into a
group that has a need that's a fantastic
way to go about doing things
contribution of the so the modes that
the ways in which people were
contributing to this wiki annotate it is
what you're saying from the
establishment and existence of a need
that brought people to that mode of
collaboration so I overhear the hanging
out the bikers can be a marketing thing
but this notion of creating a Geo wiki
for example is more of a design or an
engineering contribution in your mom um
I wouldn't say it that way okay i would
say that in order to do the design and
engineering you have to understand the
community at this stage where that
understanding happens will be different
in different projects in the industry
world you know there's this dream notion
that well the user experience person
covers everything in most companies that
are not quite as enlightened today it's
still the case that the people talking
to the to the end clients are more
likely to be marketing and market
research than they are to be technical
people who will understand that you've
gotta work in partnership in an academic
setting so some of the work that I've
done with people developing communities
for one of them specifically was people
on HIV drug cocktails another one was
for transgender individuals in both of
those communities I couldn't get the
depth of contact that I would have
needed to deal with that community
effectively in the design of a social
system I had partners that had in one
case ten years of experience with these
people in one case about seven years of
experience and the right thing was to
get that expect piece of the puzzle from
those part
nurse those partners were researchers
they were health researchers they
weren't a computer scientist they didn't
understand anything about the mechanisms
but they sure understood the issues of
the community to understand where is
identity important where's anonymity
important what's the social
relationships among the people in the
community and I think that depending on
the project you're doing those are the
kinds of things that matter okay so I'm
going to give you a different example of
a piece of work that we're now you know
roughly twelve years into and it's from
some perspective it's a highly
mathematical piece of work I'm not going
to get you into all of the math but it's
fundamentally also a social computing
piece of work it's an area we call
recommender engineering so first quick
thing how many people are familiar with
the term recommender systems you'll
notice I never asked you if you're
unfamiliar because there's no reason to
ask you to embarrass yourself but there
were hands that didn't go up so I'm
going to give a quick definition not a
lengthy one recommender systems are
these personalization systems that
typically operate on the basis of
profiles of users past preferences the
most common ones that I'm going to talk
about our collaborative systems that use
the preferences of a whole community and
attempt to provide personalized feedback
to each person so you go to Amazon you
get people who liked this like that
that's a non personalized version or
ephemeral e personalized it's
personalized to what you're looking at
but not who you are if you go to Amazon
or one of a thousand other places and
they say hey based on your past stuff
here's what you think you should go buy
today that's personalized these systems
have been around now the first published
versions the first published systems are
just over 20 years old the group lens
paper in 1994 there was at the same time
the in early 95 papers on the belk or
video recommender and the Ringo system
out of MIT and we can argue forever
about who was first
I but you can look at the dates and what
you figure out was the idea was ripe
that three different groups came up with
nearly the computationally same approach
and each submitted it for publication
before the first one got published you
know did somebody copy anybody else's
work no the idea was just ready and the
idea at the time was let's share
somebody's ratings with everybody else
and automatically use computation to
find the people most like me to give the
highest weight to when we figure out
what I'm going to like so if I think
about a movie that I want to see the
first thing I do is I might go through
the movies I've seen I say I liked
such-and-such who like that who like
this who dis like this I look at all
your hands and I pick a set of you that
look like you have my movie tastes and I
see what you folks like we can make it
more complicated than that we don't have
to the technologies old if you really
want to learn how these systems work you
can figure that out in a hundred hours
in an online MOOC on recommender systems
you can see all the lectures for free
from well me and Mike ekstrand who did a
wonderful job and we'll you know that's
that's all out there on Coursera if you
want to go find it very quickly the
shape of the field changed the first
paper published was a systems
architecture paper if you look at it it
basically said hey look we've got this
from a computational technique and it
turns out we can tag the data or have
the data ride along almost for free with
the content from place to place so that
the data can be where we need to compute
it if you look at this this was in an
era where people were not yet used to
real-time fast connections the work was
started in 92 and that paper remarkably
highly cited um mostly addresses issues
no one would have cared about today
because
nobody was worried about can i make my
ratings go along in usenet newsgroups
that might get copied at midnight when
somebody makes a long-distance call it's
just not that big a deal anymore the
other paper spent a lot focusing on
delivery and they basically focused on
the same basic issue it works its
innovative and what it meant by it works
was done differently in the different
papers from 94 to roughly ninety seven
but it works meant the thing that we
predict for you that you will like on
average you like better than the things
we say you don't like and there was a
little bit of human centricity in one of
the 97 papers that said by the way when
we deployed this with in the case of
group lens we went out to about 200
people over the Internet we gave them
newsreaders that would use our server to
go do this and what we found out was
when we displayed that something was
good they were more likely to read it
than when we displayed it was bad it
doesn't actually check whether we were
right but we also had data that they
kept using the system and other things
and you put it all together and that was
pretty good the field shifted then over
a period of years the first next shift
was that's all really cool but it's not
efficient why is it not efficient
because sure it works fine when you have
a thousand by 50 or 10,000 by you know
six thousand but when you start having
millions by tens of millions like Amazon
for instance needed you can't compute
these things fast enough all the early
systems were computing it pretty close
to real time sometimes they'd have some
pre computed values well suddenly out
came a whole bunch of papers and along
later when the Patent Office got their
patents to usually not from the same
people saying
we've got better ways to compute
something that's close enough to as good
to be useful and the field changed for a
moment because in order to measure close
enough to as good efficiently the field
needed a metric the metric that most
people used was error there's different
measures of error mean absolute error
mean squared error root mean squared
error all of them are measures that say
if I predict something as five stars on
a five star scale and you say it's four
stars I'm off by one if you say it's
three stars I'm off by two and so people
started developing more efficient
algorithms using many different
techniques relating items rather than
people was one of them that has been
very successful matrix factorization
techniques that are basically singular
value decomposition and approximations
to it if you're not familiar with the
concept basically its matrix compression
how do you reduce the rank of a matrix
with minimum loss and the rest you can
go take linear algebra and come back for
four but people took these techniques
and they said wow this stuff is about as
good sometimes it was even better
numerically and we had a running system
at that point a system called movie lens
that we launched in 1997 the movie lens
system was an accident and I say this
advisedly and what I mean by it was an
accident is that we had no intention of
writing a movie system a movie
recommender system we had been doing
usenet news recommendations and we knew
that was going to die it was way too
hard to keep the software updated for a
small number of users but we were busy
launching a company turning this into
products and the folks actually not far
from down the street at what was then
the deck systems research center in Palo
Alto had run their own movie system they
ran a system called each movie and their
research management people said you've
gotten all the research
she need out of this system shut it down
they hated the idea of just shutting it
down alone they had collected 2.7
million ratings from a whole bunch of
users they went out to the research
community is that does anybody want to
take this and do something with it we
looked around and we said huh we've got
the tools let's do it and we actually
got a master's student who replicated
each movie in a month I've never had
somebody program a system as quickly
since it was an amazing effort got it up
and running at which time decks lawyers
told us that we couldn't actually keep
or contact the users but we could use
the data and so we had to recruit new
users on our own the folks at deck
helped by mailing the users themselves
and saying if you're sad our system is
shutting down come to this one it didn't
hurt that we got some really nice
publicity at the time we we got a couple
of pieces that really helped make this
happen there were three of them that
that were notable in the history of the
system this is partly it was good timing
it was partly good luck and it was
partly the fact that the company that we
found it at the time was paying 25
thousand dollars a month for PR and and
there you can't replace that kind of
expense and the three-piece things that
got movie lens to succeed were one a
very nice piece in The New Yorker by
Malcolm Gladwell called the science of
the sleeper to a piece a piece that was
done on ABC News Nightline where they
came in and they were talking about the
commercial side but they they filmed our
system to illustrate and show how it
happened and three we got a positive
mention on at the movies with Siskel and
Ebert when they were both alive and
still doing the show and we got a whole
bunch of people I want to connect the
story back together and the story
connects back together with the fact
that something really weird happened
when all these new algorithms that new
mathematical e numerically measured to
be as good as the
algorithms when we tried to deploy them
on our system users complained why does
issues complain it took us a while to
figure it out but there were different
adjectives that different people gave
the systems not as bold the
recommendations aren't as interesting
the recommendations are too conservative
what did this mean well we've been
spending a lot of time trying to
understand how do you go from a field
that had a metric and we optimized for
it to what do you do when somebody says
that's nice it's not wrong it's just not
right and this work on recommender
engineering is an example of what came
out of that Sean makhni earned a PhD
looking at the issues of what are the
factors that might be characteristics of
an algorithm that might match to a
user's characteristics or task
characteristics or domain
characteristics how do you think about
things like boldness and serendipity and
diversity when do you want to recommend
her we had various people along the way
doing projects kaisi glurk visited us
from germany and did a wonderful project
inspired entirely by his frustration of
going to amazon and seeing
recommendations for seven or ten books
that were all basically the same well if
you liked Tolkien there are lots and
lots of editions of Tolkien out there
and if you like other things plus
Tolkien you sometimes still get all the
Tolkien and he was saying how can you
tell this system I don't like that you
know i also like travel i also like
these other things can you make them
make sense for me and the answer was
well you you could measure diversity and
if you measure diversity you can tune
for diversity you can measure what's
been called serendipity serendipity was
one that first
in one of the patent applications and
later got into the research literature
as a measure of is it unexpected it's a
weird thing to measure because in order
to know that you have to know what's
expected so you need a base line that
says oh when you're recommending movies
to somebody who likes science fiction
everybody recommends this if you
recommend this it will be expected well
should you recommend things that are
serendipitous that's a different
challenge Michael ekstrand who graduated
just last I just did that terribly you
use the grammar correctly who was
graduated it's a terrible thing to miss
state that even if it's commonly done
who was graduated with his PhD last
summer as now a faculty member it at
Texas State I built a suite of tools
including lens kit which is a research
recommender toolkit freely available if
you if you google lens kit it will take
you to it and it's whole purpose was to
say let's give people the tools where
they can produce eight or 12 or a dozen
metrics or build a live system with an
engine behind it to experiment on and
there's dozens of experiments that have
been run some buy us some by other
people in the field all of them trying
to get to this sense of engineering of
saying how do people respond to
different properties of a social
algorithm now i just gave you those
examples for one of the least social of
the social systems out there when we
started movie lens nobody was talking
about it as social computing yet the
term hadn't caught on when we first
started working with psychologists the
first two people we worked with outside
of computing we're Bob kraut and Sarah
Kessler there's a lesson in that there's
a long story but the lesson in that is
if you're going to work with people in
the field try to get some of the top
people because they have a lot of
insight and it was very interesting
because at the first meeting we had Bob
knew a lot about our system Sarah didn't
yet
she went she used it and she came back
and she said there's no community there
of course she was right we've been
talking about online community and the
community was I read a movie and in some
invisible algorithm people come out and
use that data it's community with a
really small sea and no immunity but it
it was a start for those sorts of things
and since then we've been building up
more and more social features and
continue to do that but the essence the
essence of this is doing this work took
a lot of different approaches there's
mathematical analytical work with data
sets will be honest the thing that got
movie lens the reputation it got in the
research community is neither our
brilliant interface design nor the
communities you need for another movie
recommender system it's the fact that we
made the data public for other
researchers and we can point to roughly
3,000 publications that use that data
set I have mixed feelings about that
because many of those publications can't
get at what really goes on because all
they have is the data set and they don't
have the users so they pull this back to
the point I was making generalizability
and validity if we're trying to build a
theory that can support an engineering
we're trying to build science that is
usable there's two obvious questions and
my apologies i'm sure you all learned
this somewhere you know in grade school
but if your computer science curriculum
is very much like mine was you never
learned it again afterwards unless you
took a course in the social or natural
sciences but you care about the question
of internal and external validity an
internal validity is a measure of
whether what you did you did right did
you control for everything
in social computing we have areas where
we do this really well and we have areas
where we don't do this really well but
we can conduct controlled experiments
where we do have nice job varying only
one thing except in the cases we're
doing that distorts the two populations
and obviously if the populations are
different things change we add an
interesting story we're working with a
student on this one right now where we
have a really nice research question
that we don't know how we can study
because the really nice research
question involves intervening with new
users of our system before they start to
use it except new users of our system
are extremely fragile you know when you
put a login screen in on some systems
you lose eighty percent of the people
you try to put in a survey before you
get to do anything who's left let's say
you lose seventy percent of your people
are those thirty percent like your
control group I guess you could do a
control survey that's just as painful
but has no actual content but we're also
worried that we don't want to lose
seventy percent of our users as they're
coming in you know that's what keeps the
system going so internal validity we can
deal with when we can run experiments
and we do this regularly we put up
different versions of our algorithms
different versions of our interfaces not
only on movie lens but on systems like
Psychopaths on the other systems that
we've built and see what happens
external validity is the question of how
well does the system is the set up that
you've created replicate the real world
can you generalize from this experience
it's the question we are asked every
time we try to do anything with movie
lenses does anybody actually care what
people do on a movie recommender system
the answer is no we don't even care
it's not that interesting but we care to
the extent that for the things that
we're doing a movie recommender system
might help us have insight about how
people would behave in a broader set of
systems and we're trying to address this
in our current most current research
we've been doing work on crowdsourcing
we've done it in movie lens we're doing
it in other systems to where we're
taking basically the same experiment in
replicating it across different
populations and different domains with
our fingers crossed that the results
will be the same because if the results
are the same we have some hope and
saying maybe this thing is true as a
general principle of people interacting
with social systems instead of this is
true for people who are fans of Star
Wars which is not necessarily the
direction that we want to go one more
thing mostly something I want to direct
towards towards the students here which
is about the importance of claims when
you're talking about research you know
at the end of any study and research
somebody's going to ask you well what
did you find out and that's the wrong
question we know what you found out you
found out this was a lot harder than you
thought it was going to be and it took
more time and the users really are not
as bright as you thought they would be
we all know that the real question is
should be asking is what can you claim
as a result of your work and this came
up and i'm going to give most of the
credit in this to Bonnie john formerly
of carnegie mellon now IBM she had done
a panel oh that's right she went to
Cooper Union thank you she went to
Cooper Union and now they're not tuition
free I don't think the two are
associated but I don't know and and if
it relates to her getting paid well she
deserves it she did a panel
akai a number of years ago were one of
the questions that was being asked is
does every paper that comes to KY need a
user study and you know she answered it
in the most intelligent way I've heard
that question answered which you know
started with no of course not but some
do how can you tell what are they
claiming the evaluation in your paper
depends on what you're claiming is the
contribution that people should be able
to take away and generalize from if you
build a system where I control this
slideshow by using semaphores with my
arms and I want to claim that that
system is easier to use than this remote
1 i'm an idiot but to I need a user
study probably if what I want to claim
is that that system is novel I need a
literature review and I show that nobody
has ever built one of these systems
before then when I see that claim people
will probably throw away the paper
because it's not interesting to say I
can do something that's never been done
they want a claim that says it has value
if I want to claim that it's more
accurate for something I need a study
that's going to measure accuracy which
may be a user study or it may be another
kind of study what you come back with is
going to come back with what you claim
and I'm going to say that for a minute
because we're moving to the next piece
of this where this will come back and so
what I said was you know at the
beginning I love experiments that's what
I like doing I like building stuff and
trying it out on people that doesn't
mean i run experiments all the time i
found a lovely silver bullet that was
available for sale online and i stripped
the picture out of its out of where it
was being sold and put it into my
presentation for one reason and one
reason only
why why do you want a silver bullet well
that's one reason to kill werewolves why
is the lone ranger wat silver bullets
what is it a calling card the other is
as a reminder that they're valuable that
you don't go shooting randomly and just
shooting all the time yeah I trace this
story back i'm not a huge load ranger
fan but it made a wonderful point you
know if you love experiments you don't
waste them you don't waste your users
you don't offend people by having them
do something that's that's ridiculously
half way and that means that you've need
data first you review your literature
you understand the theory that's going
on you may study usage data if you have
a live system you study your log data
you do all of those things and figure
out the questions that need those
experiments you never start by saying
well why don't I've got an interesting
question I mean there are people who do
this don't do this yourself you know if
you say I wonder whether you know people
who get products on a blue background
versus a red background are more likely
to buy the product it's a reasonable
question you don't start by building an
e-commerce site and putting red and blue
backgrounds out at random you start by
finding data from an e-commerce site and
seeing if the purchase rates on the
things that just happened to have had
blue and red backgrounds we're different
and then you might come back and say but
there's other things I couldn't control
from that you know the things on the red
backgrounds were displayed differently
there were other things now I want to
run an experiment you might need to do
that but you don't start there and so
you know there's just an amazing amount
of stuff you can do if you understand
where things are and I want to give you
a story related to this we've often in
our
or lab thought we were very clever this
has not always been a good thing we at
one point decided that it would be worth
interviewing a bunch of our users to see
if they thought we were as clever as we
thought no I'm not quite that but to
understand we went very broad we hired a
psych student turns out nothing we have
this person do require them to be a
psych student but he was looking for
something to do and we wanted to
interview a bunch of users and we
figured well he should be trained to do
that and we basically asked users why
they use the site we asked people what
how they thought it worked we had by the
way a beautiful intro screen that
explains how it works and then we got
the stories of what users really thought
and some people are laughing now because
they know the one I'm going to talk
about which is the user who thought that
the way we came up with recommendations
for this user was that we SAT around the
table and figured out what movies we
thought she would like you think about
it it's no no it's not just no more
absurd it's as plausible as saying well
no we actually have these large matrices
and the matrices magically do all of
this but you learn a lot by observing
people we did this again in another
study this is a study we did with an
economist a wonderful collaborator yan
chen at the University of Michigan and
it was a study that showed us that
everything we were thought we were doing
was based on a flawed assumption and
i'll tell you the flawed assumption
because it's such an obvious assumption
that none of us saw the flaws and the
assumption was that people use a movie
recommender
system to get recommendations for movies
it seems clear and she wanted to build
an experimental model that would show
things like how much value the system
was to people based on how many
recommendations they got and other
things like that in their usage and the
model wasn't working and we built we
dilt did a survey to find out why people
used movie lens and indeed the number
one reason people gave for using movie
lens overall was they like to get
recommendation for movies very close
behind number two was I use movie lens
to rape movies you're not shocked enough
I wouldn't understand how shocked we
were that would be like for us saying if
we ask people why do you put money in
parking meters well number one I put
money in parking meters so I can park
there and not get ticketed and number
two it's fun to put the quarters in our
model was based on the idea that rating
is a cost and the consumption of the
recommendations is a is a payoff but the
users thought the act of rating was a
payoff and it was no surprise that the
model didn't converge because our costs
were actually negative for many of the
users you get this stuff when you
actually talk to people last part of
this piece how many people here have
heard the term big data okay what is it
they don't need any memory along you
know what big data is and I'll tell you
I do analytics I like data but there is
a challenge and this is the challenge I
was talking about at the beginning that
there are a lot of papers that
are very little more than saying there
was a data set and here's what my
algorithm says about it guess what i
found a hundred and seventy-three
statistically significant correlations
how many did you look at I don't know
about four or five thousand what's your
p-value point 05 oh so you found the
random ones now you can fix that with
statistical Corrections you can stop
pure data mining but in fact a lot of
what has gone on in this in social
computing has been I've got a big data
set look at this and a lot of the great
advances have come from other things and
I don't mean to say that data analysis
is a bad thing you can diagnose problems
and find things with data analysis Oh
wonderful example of it is the data
that's out there on wikipedia that shows
for instance about the loss of new
editors huh new editors who are reverted
tend to take their marbles and go home
shocking it's not enough all by itself
but when you see the numbers shown you
realize ah turns out the follow-up paper
on that was actually more fun some
people didn't look at the follow-up
paper but the follow-up paper basically
said and you know what we would be
better off without most of those new
editors this was the paper that was
under the title Wikipedians are born not
made that said you know most of those
people if they don't do good work up
front they never turn into good
contributors oh that's sort of
interesting we need to think about this
you can sometimes understand context
prevalence details so some work that was
done by folks in our group looked at the
specifics of interactions in online
gaming
and looked at how people engage in
abusive behavior towards each other in
online multiplayer games not sufficient
work but it did show a few interesting
patterns one of the ones that I still
think is sort of interesting is that
there's a set of people who mostly are
abusive in their last game in a series
of games that gives you something to
follow up on doesn't actually tell you
what's happening but it gives you
something to follow up on frequently
analysis is great in trying to go and
develop a solution before you try it out
so analysis has a lot of places to go
but you've got to figure out where your
questions are coming from i'm going to
skip ahead because i want to move
towards a little bit of discussion and
the last couple of things i wanted to
take us through is this question of
infrastructure so I've told you a little
bit about our group I'm now going to
tell you a lot more about our group we
we like our group so this group lens
group was you know founded in the
original sense about 20 years ago John
Riedl worked with Paul Resnick at MIT to
do the original group lens system that
was published in 94 and 95 I joined them
to create a large-scale experimental
deployment that got us in our view large
scale two hundred users two hundred was
big and frankly 200 was big at the time
compared to the other things that people
were doing and other than doing
commercial spin-offs and continuing to
do work in recommender systems that of
the major milestones were i'm going to
attribute to people and systems movie
lens which i told you about 1997 we
didn't build another recommender system
for a long time we brought in lore
intervene who joined us in 2002 lauren
been built the Cyclopes system we
started in roughly that same time a
whole bunch of research including tools
experiments on wikipedia where we have
plugins and all sorts of things that
allow us to study Wikipedia work we've
started building some additional
recommender systems and systems
infrastructure there we now have a
system deployed in public libraries we
have tool kits that are out there we
have data sets we've brought in to new
faculty in the last year and a half
Brent Hecht and Lana jaros who are
bringing their own systems brent has
done work looking at intercultural data
of as expressed in Wikipedia as well as
other things and has systems for
visualizing displaying and processing
the knowledge across different languages
Lana has done experimental work
including systems that do remote
communication for separated families
looking at things like how children who
are of divorced parents or children with
deployed military parents can interact
and keep up to date we're adding one
more person who's coming this fall hi
use you and we're probably not going to
be allowed to add anybody else for
another year or two but we we pride
ourselves on infrastructure we staff for
infrastructure we have one person who's
a full time research scientist who keeps
things running and the best thing about
infrastructure is that we can control
things movie lens is still the heart of
a lot of what we do and it is the heart
because we can count on reliably new
users coming in at the rate of about 150
a week and old users coming back at six
to seven hundred a week and we talked
about we've had over a hundred thousand
users they don't all show up this week
but that allows you to run some really
interesting experiments see there's some
people in this room who made some of
that possible in the code where we can
track a person and assign them to a
random category and say you're going to
get a different experience not only
today but for the next six months and we
can measure whether you stay around
how much you contribute how much you
come back whether your ratings are more
positive or more negative we can't tell
whether you we don't have a social
network we can't tell if you're happy
yet but we can do a lot of stuff with
people because we run a system there are
some downsides to what we do it's
expensive anybody who thinks keeping a
community running is cheap it's not it
has some wonderful investment returns
for students who build stuff building
things is really rewarding but it takes
time and frankly it makes things harder
to generalize we're getting there with
enough faculty and enough students we
can do experiments across projects but
we couldn't for the first 15 years of
that platform and that's something
that's an exchange there is an
alternative people experiment out you
know it's cheaper you can use somebody
else's existing community there's just a
few big problems here one is frequently
you can't get to the systems you really
want to run the experiments in I mean I
see commercial systems I would love to
play around with and somehow Google and
Amazon and other people don't want me
messing with their customers they're
wrong I would be nice but you have to
respect them for having the right to
make that decision they put constraints
on some of the ones where you can
experiment that often stop you from
doing the experiments we want to do our
best way of experimenting is actually
sending students as interns because
sometimes as an intern you can run an
experiment but often the experiment you
can run isn't the experiment you want to
run it's the experiment they want to run
which is not always as interesting but
cooperation consent those are all
challenges and you still get these
issues of generalizability and even face
validity when you put things into a
system that you can't control things off
because there are issues there
and you know running a system is not the
same as running experiments I mentioned
this briefly but the idea of having the
logs having the a/b testing being able
to track students just expect that adds
another hundred percent to your
development effort if you want to put up
a system that just works and you want
that system to be able to support this
it's getting better there's some decent
frameworks now where you can make it add
only forty percent in some cases depends
how much of it is all web but it's extra
effort to get their last of these things
to think about as you're thinking about
research lab and field we talked about
experiments experiments a nice word but
it doesn't actually say what you're
talking about so we fundamentally run
two types of experiments in our group we
run online lab experiments where we
recruit people typically from among our
users but not always sometimes we
recruit them on Turk and other places we
put them into some special environment
we have them do something we measure the
result why do we do online lab
experiments they're easy you get really
nice internal validity you control
everything you possibly can and you
randomize anything you can't control and
you have one factor that you can study
we also do online field experiments
where you give people different
experiments so conditions and you run
them for a while and when you're dealing
with online field experiments we lose a
lot of that internal validity people
have different rates of attrition in the
different conditions you have to deal
with that people have other things that
change their behaviors but what you get
is greater external validity it reflects
what they really do in a real
circumstance and not simply what they do
when you tell them you have 20 minutes
fill out this form there's benefits to
all of those things the one we're doing
right now that to me is the most fun so
we did
a survey to ask people about algorithmic
preferences and assign them different
algorithms in our system and now they
have a system where they can go change
the algorithm as they want and we're
already seeing results coming back
saying that certain algorithms when
people try them they stay and certain
ones people leave and ironically some of
the ones that people leave are the ones
that the published literature says are
the best and the published literature is
wrong at least for our circumstance it
is the best in numerical measures it's
not the best in user experience and
that's the kind of thing that we want to
find out so about those concluding
thoughts just going to say a couple of
them one you know platforms are hard and
expensive we need to figure out how to
share them and we need to figure out how
to fund sharing them not going to say
more about that number two I know a
bunch of you are actually doing this
kind of research those people who are
more senior need to continue to push to
get this stuff rewarded it is way too
easy for somebody to look better than
you because they had seven papers last
year each of which analyzed a different
slice of a data set and all you did was
build a system the National Research
Council actually had a report that was
instrumental in my career came out i
think was 92 talking about experimental
computer scientists and engineers and
what had to be done to support those
people the number one thing it talked
about was they're not going to publish
as much you've got to measure the
artifacts that they create and the
impact of the individual publications
not just the count this probably
something needed to keep reminding
people of this experiments are hard
that's nothing new
if there's a final message I want to
give you you know what we've learned
from you no more than 20 years of doing
this stuff think about your impact
what's the question your answer does
your does what you're interested in need
experimental evidence if you need these
things think about teams how do you put
together the people that do this and and
think about the investment it's going to
take to go after the big questions
because those are the questions we all
care about I'm going to thank lots of
people all at once and invite you to
continue this with your discussion if
you need to go to apply the admit to
another class of something management
you don't need to go and just want to
ever feel that easy questions reactions
it is a thought about tell you about
India it just seems that Simpson if you
go back a few years and everyone was
saying it desktop computers people were
probably more productive than now with
mobile devices so I was just wondering
whether that's something that factor and
this is that the general change in
behavior so let me answer your question
twice I am not aware of a study that
looks at quality differences or
productivity differences of based on
whether somebody is mobile or not I'm
sure somebody's looking at that but i am
not familiar with the results and if
anybody's looking at the most likely
people are actually inside the wikimedia
foundation because they're the closest
to the data that might help determine it
it's not always easy to tell it
sometimes comes through in the in the
browser ID if you can't get it from the
browser ID it's hard to know
I ibly whether somebody's mobile or not
the question of whether people are more
productive though i think is much more
complicated than that i think there are
ways in which people are less focused
but more able to be productive
immediately in a mobile computing
setting and we see this that people get
answers to things that they used to have
to remind themselves to do later which
is a sign of productivity if you take a
task and dismiss it rather than delay it
so i'm not sure i would buy the premise
that people are necessarily less
productive because they're walking
around with things like this but it is
certainly true that you can do the
objective measures of things like text
input speeds and you know we haven't
reached the point where the population
on average can input as quickly on some
of those devices as as on a keyboard
sometimes that's not the best measure of
productivity though yeah um some of your
discussions of you know when you write
an experiment when you try to get what
contributions are you trying to make um
there's often this divide between what I
can measure people doing like input
speeds on what I actually want to show
like something old towards this will
save the world where people really love
this or something more abstract like it
a lot of UX stuff so I do crowdsourcing
working looking at people won't like the
task they won't do it I can't measure
that I can't say well I put this on
Turkey nobody did it and if I had to
make it better you know I have to bring
it up to a level where it's enjoyable
enough to compete with everything else
and um but does it really argue myself
ready they're the most important um oh
they're not always hard to measure they
can be mean you can actually do
experiments to measure things like
appeal of tasks if that's the question
you want to get to the problem I think
you're raising is that's not what you're
studying that's just what you need to
get through to get to what you're
studying
and this is part of the challenge of the
work that we're doing in in this field
is and this is why I say that that
approach us start with claims is so
valuable if you go back and say well
what is it that you want to do you don't
you're not going to get directly to the
conclusion i saved the world but unless
you're going to make a claim that saving
time is important in something showing
that it's faster may not have a lot of
value you do need to find something that
you can measure that you can also make a
connection to why it's important and
that's often the role of theory and it's
also often the role of models that you
can come back and show okay you know we
have a model we have theory from
economics that shows the productivity
leads to income it's not perfect but we
understand the notion that if we can
make workers more productive then in a
free market they can command a greater
income because one of the factors that
determines their income is the amount
that they produce for their employer in
whatever form it is if you start with
that you now have an opera or e you know
theoretical justification for saying if
we can make this faster we can help
people it may be enough to show that you
can make it faster it may be that you
need something that's a bigger chain
than that but taking the theoretical
results that are out there in the prior
work lets you set your work in a context
where the thing you can show you can
connect the dots eventually for many of
those things somebody has to show that
you know what you've done is not just
prove the exception that well people
make more if they work faster except in
your domain but that's not where you
have to worry about first start by
making the connection to the things that
people have already shown yeah ah okay
so I like to actually give you another
soap box just because I'd like to hear
your thoughts just cuz I'd like to hear
your thoughts so you talked a lot about
you talked a lot about infrastructure
you talked a lot about experiments when
I'm thinking about research
contributions are talking with students
there's also so the role of we might
call systems which is maybe more more of
me I might put it this way engineering
might be about taking being able to
transform a problem statement into an
approach that is likely to work like
build a bridge that works the arts what
you call art in many ways I feel like is
about the contributions feel like
they're I'm giving you a new color a new
kind of paint brush something that
allows you to do something that you
weren't able to do before and I felt
like that was a little bit less
represented in your presentation so I
wonder what your take is on when we
should be entering each mode of research
so I haven't I think that's really
important research it's not what I
mostly do which is why I didn't talk
that much about it I value the people
who do it but I think it's critically
important to come up with environments
where somebody and it's not always the
person who has the technical ability to
make the new paint brush somebody
figures out what that new paint brush is
good for and you know we have this
interesting child I mean I spent a fair
bit of time in the whist community the
user interface software and technology
community and in its early days we had a
lot of papers including some by me that
were basically Hey look I can do this
and I think the community needed that it
needed somebody to show all the things
you could do so that other people could
put those components together into
something somebody would want to do you
know my contribution was we can build a
tool kit that's based on the principles
of programming languages in the end the
paper was well received and nobody ever
did anything with that again because
none of us knew why you would want to do
that it was just intellectually fun to
try
and it's okay to do some of that but i
think that the stuff that's really
impressive to me and this comes up
probably biggest ball in areas where
people are talking about creativity
support is to create environments where
you say well when i put this in there
i'm actually finding that people are
being more creative or being creative
more effectively or with less
frustration or are able to manage larger
teams or able to get by with smaller
teams or whatever the right measure is
and the challenge with that kind of work
and I mean I've talked to a number of
people who do some of it is it's
painstaking to get people to adopt a new
technology you can't do it the first
time through but you can start with the
idea that at least I know what this is
going to be good for I tie it to some of
the theoretical things and then I think
that work is just incredibly important
for our field I mean to me it's it's not
fundamentally different for us than the
people who are doing quantum computing
these days because you know the first
question of well can you make a computer
that uses this stuff is sort of
interesting but it's not worth that much
investment until those folks came back
and said you know what we have a whole
group of people who are working on not
how do you build a quantum computer but
if it existed what problems can you
solve with it and a different set of
people that are working on how do you
make it work and some who overlap and
with those two groups of people working
together that may turn into something
really important if the second group
didn't come around to figure out what to
do with it you know people would look
that's a cool qubit what's next and
unfortunately I think that happened with
a lot of the early pointing technologies
where people showed every possible way
to point it's just overwhelm people with
yeah there's lots of ways to point
what's wrong with the one I have right
now and you know I guess the answer in
in very pithy terms is yes if you build
a better mouse come to your door or
whatever the question
you